and so after connections you have the
part of the journey called new
directions and new directions is when
you're discovered goal happens in in a
hero's journey the hero goes off to
right or wrong and whether they write
the wrong or not that's the whole movie
are they going to save the rebellion or
not and they might meet Yoda along the
way but their goal stays the same really
but in comedy because your characters
start off as as missing apart or broken
their initial goals are broken as well
they're short-sighted they're not really
the best the best for their for the
character and the discovered goal is
what the characters discover along the
way what they really want bill murray
starts groundhog day thinking all he
needs all that would make his life
perfect would be to be a weatherman in a
big at a bigger better station but along
the way he realizes what he really wants
is having a real relationship and
specifically a real relationship with
rita in in tropic thunder
the initial goal for all the actors is
simply to get back to the base camp and
get out of the jungle where you might
step on a landmine and blow yourself up
but along the way they realize that
their fellow actor Ben Stiller has been
captured by these drug lords and so you
have them have a different goal their
goal now is simply not well do we just
leave them here and go back or do we try
to save him even though we're just
actors we're not action heroes we're not
really soldiers and that's when another
important part of a comedy comes out is
decision points you need real decision
points in terms of your comic hero's
journey you want to avoid a situation
where there's no question
of what your character is going to do
it's it's completely obvious the way it
should go
why even bother wasting my time one
example of that in an you know otherwise
well-received movie but one I thought
did not really give its character its
protagonists a great decision point is
Midnight in Paris because in Midnight in
Paris Owen Wilson had to choose between
this whining harp harpy of a girlfriend
who he's engaged to or one of the women
that he's met in his time travels in in
Paris of earlier years and to me that's
not a real decision point do you really
think he's going to give up the romance
of of Paris and go back to California
with this really annoying woman a better
decision point is in a nother romantic
comedy Sleepless in Seattle in which meg
Ryan is engaged to Bill Pullman and Bull
Pullman is a great guy but is he the guy
and that's a really great decision point
because you could support her going
either way you could see it from her
point of view going either way you know
there's this maybe waiting for at the
top of the Empire State Building but
there's Bill Pullman right in front of
you being such a nice guy so you want
real decision points and in spy you see
Melissa McCarthy having those real
decision points she she has a new goal
her goal is no longer to just have Jude
Law be her boyfriend yes it's this whole
mission started out as a way of kind of
avenging him in fact she she often hurts
her her adversaries by saying that's for
you no that's for Bradley but eventually
her goal changes her goal isn't just to
avenge Bradley fine
her goal is to do what she was meant to
do which is I can do this I can be this
spy I had these skills I don't have to
hide behind somebody else I can do this
and end I can save the world I can save
the world from having terrorists get
this nuclear bomb and so you see this
moment in which she's been given the
instructions follow and report do
nothing else and there's there's a bad
guy who's running away from her that's
obviously the best lead to get to where
the nuclear bomb is being hidden and you
see it in that moment do I just follow
orders or do I follow my own emerging
transforming sense of self and do what I
think is right and so at that moment we
see her discover a new goal for herself
her new goal is no matter what she's
going to see this through to the end
you